zum politischen tagesgespräch begrüße
ich heute in bielefeld grasl man sie ist
die parlamentarische geschäftsführerin
der grünen bundestagsfraktion grund tag
vor hasselmann
ja das ist ja ein starkes stück in
anführungsstrichen ausgerechnet zu
beginn der dritten welle leistet sich
die politische klasse eine veritable
diskussion über die frage wer ist
zuständig der bund oder die länder und
annalena baerbock ihre vorsitzende die
haben ja gerade schon gesehen sagt es
dürfe es kein rumgeeiere mehr geben und
fordert maßnahmen nämlich weitere
schärfere maßnahmen um die dritte welle
zu brechen frau hoffmann heißt das wenn
die kanzlerin tatsächlich an dieses
infektionsschutzgesetz ran gehen würde
hätte sie die unterstützung der grünen
in sachen panini bekämpfung sind wir
alle gefordert bund länder und kommunen
wir kriegen das nur gemeinsam hin das
ist unsere grundhaltung aber ja klar
wir sagen seit monaten lasst uns
gemeinsam im bund im parlament einen
stufenplan beschließen
der deutlich macht auf welcher grundlage
und an welchen werten orientiert wir
verschärfung lockerung öffnung oder auch
drastische einschränkung maßnahmen
beschließen und das flankiert durch
änderungen im infektionsschutzgesetz das
ist unsere haltung hier drängen wir seit
monaten sowohl die bundesregierung als
auch die sie tragenden fraktionen cdu
csu und spd
und mir ist völlig unklar warum bisher
diese weigerung erfolgt mit uns zusammen
einen stufenplan der mehr
bundeseinheitlichen rahmens gleichzeitig
aber auch kriterien benennt und
perspektiven für die bürgerinnen und
bürger klar macht was passiert wenn und
das ganze dann auch noch auf eine
rechtsstaatlich festere grundlage
stellen
dass es unserer auffassung und wir
müssen jetzt angesichts der
beunruhigenden situation was das
infektionsgeschehen angeht wirklich die
notbremse zwar schon man welche
erklärung haben sie dafür dass das nicht
geschieht was sie und andere ja auch
seit längerer zeit fordert ich meine
dieser streit ist ja kein
parteipolitischer streit
es ist ja mehr ein streit zwischen bund
und ländern warum verhalten sich die
ministerpräsidentin und minister
ministerpräsidenten so weil die mehr
wissen was im land los ist weil die
wissen dass die menschen nicht mehr
können oder welche erklärungen gibt es
dafür
ich glaube dass die bundesregierung viel
zu lange auf sicht gefahren ist immer
nur auf sicht fahren kleine schritte
vereinbaren
wir haben noch immer keine umfangreiche
test strategie ja das ganze konzept was
ministerpräsidentinnen und
bundeskanzlerin vor drei vier wochen bei
der vorletzten
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz diskutiert
haben kann der vor sogenannten
vorsichtigen lockerung kann doch nur
passieren wenn wir eine umfangreiche
test strategie gehabt hätten
die lag aber doch in vielen regionen gar
nicht vor wir sind viel zu langsam beim
impfen
und wir haben gleichzeitig durch die
virus mutation eine unglaubliche zunahme
von neuinfektionen
und in diese situation hinein muss man
doch sagen dass die beschlüsse einer
vorsichtigen öffnung strategie
lockerungs strategie kombiniert damit
dass eine umfangreiche tests strategie
und auch ein schnelleres impfen nicht
funktionieren muss man sagen das war ein
fehler
und hier brauchen wir jetzt klarere
maßnahmen wir brauchen
bundeseinheitliche kriterien weil die
situation was das infektionsgeschehen
angeht einfach doch eine erschreckende
zunahme zeigt ja die zahlen sprechen da
eine deutliche sprache übrigens in
sachen test strategie sagen ja jetzt die
minister
präsidentin unisono die strategie ist
angelaufen beispielsweise nordrhein
westfalen verfügt sagt armin laschet
über 6.000 test punkte das lassen wir
jetzt mal dahin gestellt sein wie gut
das funktioniert laschet hat gestern
angekündigt dass er über eine
staatsreform sprechen will
frau casselman an welchem punkt sehen
sie den größten reformbedarf der jetzt
in der pandemie offensichtlich geworden
ist also ich versteh armin laschet
überhaupt nicht zum einen legt er die
beschlüsse von vor drei vier wochen der
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz jetzt
plötzlich so aus als sei das eine
flexible notbremse was soll das
eigentlich angesichts der zahl der
neuinfektionen
wir müssen jetzt handeln und wir
brauchen jetzt in dieser situation der
pandemie keine grundsatzdebatten über
föderalismus ein hand in hand zwischen
bund ländern und kommunen ist notwendig
aber es braucht dazu ein
bundeseinheitlichen stufenplan und es
braucht eine änderung des
infektionsgeschehen desinfektions
gesetzes und wenn die bundeskanzlerin
sagt sie will dem parlament hier was
vorlegen wir sind jederzeit bereit als
grüne hier zu einer sitzung des
bundestages zusammen zu kommen dann soll
eine vorlage
da sein wir setzten uns damit
auseinander
wir fordern das seit monaten und bitte
jetzt keine grundsatzdebatten über die
frage von föderalismus das können wir
jetzt wirklich nicht gebrauchen in der
lage der palmen
aber leute die in deutschland leben also
ausländer in deutschland leben
beschreiben uns deutsche des öfteren als
penibel als langsam als ein bisschen
bräsig ich will damit sagen muss ich in
diesem land nicht einiges mehr ändern
als in den politischen
entscheidungsstrukturen nämlich auch an
der mentalität der bürger wir müssten in
sachen pandemie bekämpfung klar
schneller werden gründlicher werden und
wir ich habe ja am beispiel der test
strategie und auch am beispiel der frage
des impfens deutlich gemacht hier muss
klarer und schneller gehandelt werden
der zugang von allen bürgerinnen und
bürgern zum impfen zur test strategie
muss für schneller muss schneller
stattfinden
das ist ganz klar aber wir können uns
doch jetzt in der pandemischen lage in
der wir sind
die dritte welle die anrollt keine
grundsatzdebatten über föderalismus
brauchen wir brauchen beschlüsse im
deutschen bundestag die auch für die
bürgerin klar machen nach welchen
kriterien wird hier eigentlich was
entschieden wann gibt es einschränkende
maßnahmen die uns alle sehr belasten
wann wird gelockert vankann geöffnet
werden da braucht es doch mehr
planbarkeit mehr perspektive für die
menschen für die wirtschaft für den
einzelhandel vor allen dingen für die
kinder in den schulen und kitas
darum geht es jetzt und nicht um die
frage was können wir uns leisten wenn
die pandemie vielleicht mal hinter uns
liegt zu sagen ist eigentlich unsere
organisation ist das gut ausgebaut wir
würden auch viele sachen einfallen
ich will zum beispiel dass die
öffentliche gesundheitsdienst dass der
öffentliche gesundheitsvorsorge gestärkt
wird das zeigt sich schon heute aber
grundsatzdebatten
die brauchen wir nicht jetzt jetzt
brauchen wir klares und entschiedenes
handeln in der pandemie bekämpfung und
die grundsatzdebatte über föderalismus
die können wir dann gerne danach führen
mein eindruck ist armin laschet will
hier ein bisschen ablenken davon dass er
jetzt auch nicht nur in nordrhein
westfalen sondern als auch als chef der
cdu in der verantwortung ist zu
entscheiden und zu handeln da scheint
ihm ganz offenkundig sehr schwer zu
fahren sagt britta haßelmann die
parlamentarische geschäftsführerin der
grünen im deutschen bundestag vor allem
an vielen dank für ihre zeit und einen
schönen tag noch nach ostwestfalen gerne
danke tschüss